now with bianca it's been a busy monday
morning and
on top of that the road closures we got
folks headed back to school our sixth
ninth and twelfth graders so
be sure that you're being cautious we
may have some student drivers out there
so overall traffic mats still looking
good more friends out there on the
roadways this is a look down at the
south part of our valley 15 and blue
diamond you can see an emergency vehicle
off on the right side of the shoulder
not impacting traffic at all but just a
live look for you there is a crash with
injury right near the airport
this is on sunset and so again there may
be some emergency vehicles attending to
that person
in that crash so use caution if you're
in that area now this was an area that
was closed because of police activity
you can see it since been cleared this
is that valley view in meadows
they are investigating a homicide and
again we have a crew there learning more
information thinking that it
happened at the nearby gas station so
use caution still in that area i'm
pretty sure they're still on scene
you know interviewing witnesses and
things like that and then also there was
police activity here on sahara
near paradise and eastern that has since
been cleared
they still may be out there
investigating she'll be sure to use
caution and remember that text message
it can wait
alex all right thanks bianca 6 22
and after the break here